hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest
shocking events in the boku no hero
story
including a surprise attack on deku
and all might and the huge revelation
that there may really be a way for all
for one to steal
one for all this was absolutely crazy so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero videos
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going just leave a like and comment
it only takes a second and it's a
totally free way to support
this channel and of course if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications by the way we just dropped
a brand new video here on the channel
that explains the backstories
of every single student in class 1a
definitely check out that video after
this one it took a long time to make
link in the description finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the story starts off with
a bunch of minor villains going on a
rampage
inside a mall thankfully endeavour is on
the scene
and he notices right away that the
villains are using support items and
other modifications that were created by
detnarat i'm not even sure if that's how
you pronounce it but
basically detnarat is the support item
company whose leader turned out to be
re destro himself so this is yet another
reminder that the paranormal liberation
army
is still around yes many of their
leaders have been arrested
but we know that many others did not get
arrested and managed to get away
so it's not really surprising that the
paranormal liberation army
is still active in some capacity it is
highly likely that they are playing an
active role
in orchestrating all of this chaos
across japan
endeavour then uses a cool long range
attack tentatively called
ignited arrow to launch an arrow-shaped
flame at one of the villains
the villain is taken down by the attack
and as he lies
injured on the ground he says that all
of this was endeavour's fault
anyway endeavor then respond by saying
that's why
i'm here and i actually thought that
this brief little statement
was quite symbolic all might was known
for his famous
i am here phrase which reassured people
that the symbol of peace would save them
and make everything right endeavour is
now using a variation of this phrase as
well
but the context he is using it in is
different
both all might and endeavour are saying
that they are here to defeat villains
and save the people but while
almight was the symbol of peace and
everyone's hero
endeavour is now more of an anti-hero
endeavor is not just here to save people
but also to atone for his own sins
and right the wrongs that he himself
committed endeavor is here is the
current
number one pro hero but he is not
almight
and he never will be he is a different
kind of person and a different kind of
hero
and i just thought that his little i am
here moment did a great job of
showcasing both the similarities and the
differences between him and all might at
the same time
ultimately endeavour succeeds in taking
down the villains and resolving the
situation
he hands the villains off to the police
and then he meets up with best genius
and hawks it seems that this specific
group of villains was also connected to
muscular and the big villain
jailbreak but just like with muscular
these villains don't seem to have any
valuable
intel on the big boss all for one all of
this villain activity seems to be
decentralized rather than a deliberate
and planned
act by all for one himself so whenever
they capture the villains they realize
that none of them actually know how to
get
to all for one the discussion between
the top three heroes
is suddenly cut short as a group of
angry protesters moves towards them
the outraged citizens who seem to be
armed with makeshift projectiles
tell the heroes to get out of their
neighborhood if these heroes had
actually done their jobs and prevented
the jailbreak
then muscular and his gang would never
have destroyed this entire neighborhood
and by the way the crowd and the heroes
seem to be referring to muscular
as jailbreaker so i'm guessing that this
is like a new alias that he's been using
after breaking out of tartarus the
protesters are especially angry at
endeavour
because they blame him for all the
crimes that dobby has committed
and they also believe that endeavour is
still keeping important secrets from the
public
the protesters then begin pelting the
heroes with rocks
water bottles and cans and everything
else that they can get their hands on
so the heroes take off in the genus
mobile with hawks riding
shotgun and endeavour riding in the back
seat
for his part headshot is investigating
the paranormal liberation front but it
seems that he hasn't made any progress
at least not yet
hawks then suggests that the top three
heroes should keep their distance from
deku and almight
since they don't want all of that harsh
public scrutiny that is now targeting
them to start spreading to deku as well
endeavour agrees that they should keep a
distance from deku so as not to add to
his
already massive burden and endeavor then
goes on to officially confirm
what i've been saying on this channel
ever since we first learned about deku's
decision to leave the ua
deku did not leave the ua just so his
classmates wouldn't become targets for
all for one due to their proximity to
deku although that was
certainly part of the reason deku also
volunteered to become debate for smoking
out
all for one and the league of villains
all for one and the other main villain
leaders are laying low
until they can find a way to complete
shigaraki's procedure
and perfect his body and so all of this
other seemingly random and decentralized
villain activity
is likely just supposed to be a
distraction for the heroes
all for one hopes that the heroes will
be too busy fighting off the random
villain threats
across japan to devote a ton of
resources to finding him in shigaraki
and if the heroes can't locate shigaraki
before his procedure is complete
then the heroes lose because shigaraki
will be practically
impossible to stop theoretically now
that the heroes are clearly
understaffed and disorganized all for
one may be able to actually take
advantage of the situation
and go on the offensive but endeavor
believes that deku was right when he
said that all for one's top priority
is perfecting shigaraki's procedure and
then taking over shigaraki's body
for all for one that is even more
important than taking advantage of this
chaotic situation to dunk
on the heroes and that is when endeavour
drops an absolute bombshell once
shigaraki's procedure has been completed
the next goal of all for one and the
villains
will become possible and that goal is to
steal
one for all and this is a huge
deal because initially we were all led
to believe that one for all cannot be
stolen period because of course it is a
quirk that can only be transferred
willingly
from one user to another but if that
were the case
then why would a highly intelligent
villain mastermind like all for one
spent decades of his life trying to do
something that could never be done
why would he waste all this time trying
to steal
one for all unless he knew that there
was some way to
actually steal the quirk if there was
literally no way to steal
it he wouldn't keep trying to do this
for generations
hawks then explains that according to
decline all might
shigaraki's body will need to heal and
become stronger before he can accept
the power of all for one into his body
even if he was to steal it
so that is part of the reason why
perfecting shigaraki's body
is all for one's top priority at the
moment
but the physical requirement is not the
only requirement
best genius points out that because one
for all carries within it the spirits of
the eight
former users anyone who is trying to
steal the quirk will need a willpower
that can
overcome all of their wills according to
hawks
one potential way in which this can be
achieved is through incredible amounts
of hatred it is possible that all for
one chose
shigaraki as his successor because of
his raging and seemingly
endless amount of hatred for the hero
society a hatred that all for one hopes
will be able to overcome
deku's will and the will of the former
one for all users
this seems to suggest that it is indeed
possible for shigaraki to steal one for
all
if his body is perfected and if his
hatred can overcome the wills of all the
current
and former one for all users this is
certainly not an easy task
and hawks still isn't sure if it would
work but this is one
possible way to actually steal one for
all i am not sure
if this exact method of stealing will
pan out
but i am convinced that some possible
way of stealing the quirk must exist
if it didn't the highly intelligent and
extremely experienced villain mastermind
that is
all for one would have given up on this
pipe dream long ago
and let's be real it's just more
interesting plot wise if there is a real
possibility of deku losing one for all
the stakes are much higher if that is
the case
and if all of these crazy reveals
weren't enough we then witness
another shocking event first deku's gps
signal
suddenly vanishes from everyone's radar
as all might tries to figure out what's
going on
someone throws an explosive device at
his car
we then see a big explosion and we have
no idea whether all might made it out of
the explosion or not
whoa this came out of nowhere and with
how weak
all might is right now this could prove
to be very dangerous for him
i don't think that an explosion would
kill such an important character
off-screen but it could seriously injure
him and take him out of commission
in this crucial moment we then learned
that someone had shot off
deku's communicator as he tried to reach
all might
as deku turns around he sees that female
villain from
tartarus prison she has a quirk that
allows her to grow a giant
sniper rifle out of her elbow and this
sniper is now
trained squarely on deku the villain
waifu expresses her intention to capture
deku and take him with her and she warns
him that he must follow her orders if he
wants his limbs to stay attached
to his body gekko believes that this
woman is an assassin
sent directly by all for one and next to
the woman we see a man
sitting on the rooftop and leaning
against a wall
the man's face is bathed in shadows and
we can't really see it
but the man appears to be missing both
of his hands
which of course implies that this man is
overhaul don't forget that the villain
waifu had gone
out of her way to break overhaul out of
prison back in tartarus
so he must be an important part of her
plan in some way
and that is how this shocking chapter
ends
with decline all might ambushed by the
new female villain
and with overhaul just casually
listening to my chemical romance in the
background
man where do i even start when it comes
to this chapter
and all of the questions that it raises
first of all
what is this woman's quirk her ability
to grow a massive gun out of her arm
makes her look like some sort of cyborg
terminator but is this her actual quirk
like she can grow a gun out of her arm
and that's it
or is her quirk the ability to create
any object from her body kind of like
momo
don't forget that she managed to break
overhaul out of his cell back in
tartarus
but it didn't look like she used a giant
rifle to do it so what is her quirk
i can already hear the crazy theories
about this woman being related to momo
and possessing creation or something
similar
oh wait i didn't actually hear anyone
say it so i guess i'm the crazy one
because that theory totally popped into
my head
since this woman does kind of look like
momo but what do you guys think
could her quirk be some form of creation
and if so
is she related to momo and the yao yoda
zoos in any way
if she was that would be totally nuts
momo is such a good and proper girl
and her family is wealthy and highly
esteemed but who knows
maybe they have a black sheep in the
family a secret supervillain
with the power of creation also what is
overhaul doing here i mean aside from
listening to my chemical romance
is he there by choice or is he a
prisoner of this female villain
and if he is a prisoner is it because
all for one wants to use overhaul's
quirk
to fully restore shigaraki's body we
have to remember that overhaul has the
ability to disassemble
and reassemble human bodies and when he
does reassemble the bodies they are
perfectly healthy
and free from all injuries with that
said though
overhaul's quirk is activated when he
touches something with his fingers
and currently he doesn't have hands so
does
all for one plan on stealing overhauls
quirk and then using it himself to heal
shigaraki that sounds plausible to me
but let me know if you guys agree down
below
finally do you think that deku is about
to be captured
or will he overpower the villains i
could totally see him using one of his
newest quirks to win the fight
but then again he wants to serve as bait
to locate all for one so i could also
see him
letting himself be captured and taken
directly to all for one
i mean maybe getting captured and taken
to all for one was deku's plan
all along but presumably he would have
wanted the pro heroes to track his
location so that they can show
up and defeat all for one now with
deku's gps tracker seemingly destroyed
this could prove to be a lot more
difficult oh and by the way do you think
all might is okay
please share your thoughts on this
shocking chapter down in the comments
below
if you enjoy our boku no hero videos and
you want to see more content
like this on the channel please leave
that like it only takes a second but it
helps a lot
and if you are new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works
don't forget to check out our new class
1a backstories video
link in the description and in the
pinned comment
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma
red haired raven and av these guys are
absolute mad lads and disciples of lord
twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chi bang
emperor otaku spidey life canal tungsten
targus
baked buddhist and you know finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
rathu indeora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joy and
garcia ted no ted
isparky65 jessica lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you